covet 19 is devastating communities of
color can vaccines counter racial
inequity
uh and that's there and okay that's
probably it that's all we need to see
for here
um actually zach would you put up the uh
i've got
screenshot of the new york times um
yeah here we go so this is from a piece
in the new york times that was published
on december 5th but updated december
15th so it's been reviewed
recently and it says
uh harold schmidt an expert in ethics
and health policy at the university of
pennsylvania said that it is reasonable
to put essential workers ahead of older
adults given their risks
and that they are disproportionately
minorities older populations are whiter
dr schmidt said society is structured in
a way that enables them to live longer
instead of giving additional health
benefits to those who all
who already had more of them we can
start to level the playing field
a bit so um
how many different ways is this wrong
it's pretty spectacular that we would be
playing this out i will say actually
it's a very fitting following on our
corrections i
i'm gonna say uh i predicted this one
because i said
where is this all going it's going to go
to
reparations in every interaction
at every scale 24 hours a day seven days
a week 365 days a year
and that's effectively what this is is
that people are being programmed such
that
any place where you could distribute
things differently based on race
it's assumed to be a good thing and it's
just
you know there there are a couple of
demographic markers
that uh everyone seems compelled to
elevate at every other cost at the
moment
pushing that one slider all the way to
maximum thus
reducing outcomes minimizing the effects
on
of these decisions on outcomes for every
other possible category not just
within that category obviously it's
going to have health effects on
older white adults but it also means
that there are going to be effects for
for everyone else hey we've got a
visitor for the first time in a while a
visitor who very definitely has adaptive
immunity
yes he does um so i i don't exactly know
where
you all are headed here i know there are
some things about this i i
am multitudes now yes i i believe we all
are but um
but anyway i think you've ever called me
you all before it was you all
two separate words so i don't i think
i'm on safe ground but
um go for it but in any case um
so to be clear the cdc and most of what
we know i think comes from a
slide deck in which they presented this
material
and they go through an analysis it's not
a super high quality analysis but it's
sort of
um you want to just show a little bit
yeah you want to show a little bit they
they do their little matrix thing you
want to
uh zach you want to i have it on my
screen zach
there we go you want to scroll up okay
so this is coming out
all right so let's get down to there oh
so here they're basically arguing that
there are uh
three different categories competing
they're they're alluding to trade-offs i
think kind of
ham-fistedly but nonetheless they're
alluding to trade-offs but i would also
point out that this once again reminds
us
that um the sort of the hashtag slogans
that are accompanying the culture wars
um always pretend that there are no
tradeoffs so you know the one that
uh you know that i've talked about most
in the past is hashtag believe all women
really all the time no matter what
they're saying under any circumstances
right
um and then another one is is it follow
the science
you know like what is it yeah something
about like
always trust the science under under all
circumstances no matter what
and here we have well like no and like
this is not what they're doing they are
recognizing frankly that there are
trade-offs
and that um and that they're they're
they're not
just going to follow the science at all
moments
um yes you want me to scroll down
somewhere yeah i do want you to scroll
down some more
i mean i i fully believe that actually
the science doesn't
you know it depends how you categorize
this right but um the science doesn't
answer the question what you should do
it can
if it's done right it can answer the
question of what is the case what are
the facts
but then the ethical part is distinct
yeah but okay so under ethics they've
got promote justice by which of course
they mean promote social justice by
which of course they mean
capital s capital j 2020 brand social
justice which is about equity
and not about equality so let us be
really clear here
in some sense they are arguing
for race-based medical triage
right triage being the mechanism whereby
when you don't have the resources to
save everybody as in on a battlefield
situation
and prioritize um those who are
best able to make use of what efforts
you have and you may let people die who
could be saved
because uh you know it's it's a required
phenomenon the question is
race-based triage really that's how
we're going to do this yeah
okay so okay now go ahead
i was i was gonna did you stop here for
a reason no i just have a couple more
things to say on the subject but but go
for it no go for it
um there are a couple of things i'm
going to need my screen back here zach
there are a couple of things that this
reminds me of um and one of them is a
word that we said at the same moment
when we were talking about this morning
which is tuskegee like the the tuskegee
syphilis uh study which started in
what is it 1932 targeted black men
and allowed black men to die of cephalus
even long after treatment was known and
available even long after i think it was
penicillin
was understood to be treatment for it um
and you know in fact i went back and
looked at the new york times uh which is
uh you know quoting this um
this health expert saying that we should
not give the vaccine to older people
because they're primarily white first
the new york times back in 97 and
earlier also did a good job
explaining why um this tuskegee was
appalling right and everything in what
the cdc
is saying in the slide deck now is is
not only race-based
but presumes that the vaccine is an
unalloyed good
that there is there is no question at
all
about um sure efficacy but primarily
safety
and if there is if there is anything to
the many concerns that have been raised
very few of which are saying
oh the mri the mrna vaccine is bad most
of what you're saying like we did last
week
we cannot know yet then what if
by actually doing race-based uh medicine
here
we are repeating something like what was
done in the early 20th century
it's it's it's frankly completely
appalling you know
it's it's it's racist either way either
way
and just one more thing to that end
because we don't know the long-term
effects of the vaccine
and because there is reason to think
that there might be long-term effects of
the vaccine
that is actually another reason to
prioritize
older people in getting the vaccine
not only because they are more likely to
have very bad outcomes from it
but because if there are very long-term
effects of the vaccine
they are less likely to be revealed in
those people
yeah um the the thing here
is this is an experiment
being run at a scale that um
is it fair to say that there has never
been at least medically speaking
it's going to be hard to come up with a
case in which
there was a broader scale experiment in
long-term
consequences maybe there is something
but the
the degree to which this is rapid
deployment of something
novel that doesn't mirror anything we
have
experience with in the absence of any
mechanism that might tell us what the
long-term consequences are
this is an experiment being run at an
unprecedented scale
and the idea that based on race people
are going to be advanced in this
cannot help but um imply
that at some level we are willing to run
that experiment
first on people because they've been
disadvantaged
which you know it's a gamble could it be
that
being high on the list of the vaccine
ends up working out for you of course it
could be this vaccine could be just as
promising let us hope
that everyone who receives the vaccine
uh gets a health boost from it gets a
healthy boost
that's what media side effects are low
and that the long term you know i mean
there's lots not known here including
whether or not this has any positive
effect on
transmission right right explicitly not
known at all excuse me explicitly not
known
so provides may provide some immunity
for the person getting it but whether or
not if they have it
they're less likely to transmit it we
know nothing yeah um so anyway this is a
an argument that in this context i i
believe completely accidentally
amounts to running an experiment on
disadvantaged people that's their
argument
you know by giving them the vaccine
first while we are
effectively lying to ourselves about how
much we know about how safe it is
yeah um so yes echoes of tuskegee indeed
um all right can you scroll further down
in there so they have this matrix
analysis here science implementation
ethics they've got mysteries here and
then
as you go through the slide deck they
fill these things in and they give
ranks and it's all very
pseudo-quantified
so they begin to fill these things in
and as they do it what they
reason so this is their reasoning
whether true or not
is that prioritizing hold on for people
who are listening and not watching
um it's a matrix of three columns three
rows science
implementation and ethics that same
diagram that shows up throughout
and then the columns are essential
workers non-health care about 87 million
people this is u.s
adults with high risk medical conditions
over 100 million
incidentally high-risk medical
conditions includes obesity
and either former or current smoker
which is how that number is so big
um and adults age over at 65 or over
years of age uh 53 million right
okay so the
result if you scroll down we got one
more another matrix there it is so
here's how they have
uh oh no no this is a different matrix
well this is becoming confused but let's
just say the sum
total of what they did was determine
that they would save more lives if they
gave it
to the elderly um but yes the ethical
implications as they
as they read them suggest that there is
a reason
in spite of the fact that we would save
more lives if we gave them to the
elderly to prioritize
essential workers first now so
there is you know as there is an echo of
tuskegee here there is an
echo of eugenics here too right there is
you know if if we read that you know in
the 30s
that there had been a you know a
terrible flu in
in germany or in europe and
you know that the nazis had decided to
deny
jews vaccines right we'd understand it
completely it would fit perfectly with
that story we would understand it as
what it was and then in this case
because everything's on its head
you've got a um you know a kind of
nonsense that sort of superficially well
these people are
more disadvantaged therefore priority to
the vaccine levels the playing field
even that
language is kind of creepy um yeah i
mean it is the same language
of of you know old old-school racists
and specifically anti-semites look at
how much the jews have gotten in the
world and we just we need to
take from them what they have that isn't
rightfully theirs right advantages so
therefore i mean it's very much the same
language right so now
the at the bar i've done a lot of
thinking about this and the question is
is there
anything at all to what they're trying
to do
is there's some hint of reality under
this and i i sort of think look if you
made the argument that there are some
neighborhoods for example that have been
disproportionately hit
because for whatever reason you know the
way they get to work
puts them in danger people who have been
watching our live streams will remember
the
subway issue and the issue of local
trains versus express trains
right there are certain places you can
live that put you in danger and those
things
these you know whether you're in danger
based on where you live or where you
work is not evenly distributed by race
were they to say look we are going to
deploy these vaccines
in the places where they stand to do the
most good and that happens
to be racially biased i wouldn't have an
objection to it
right but the idea that you know you're
going to categorize
all of these essential workers right
okay so now you've prioritized essential
workers
over people who are even more
disadvantaged and don't have a job
you know from the same neighborhood why
did you do that right if you're really
trying to correct
a disadvantage with a vaccine which
doesn't make sense
right then the point is you've done it
so clumsily that it can't be defended
and you know we're at neighborhoods you
know where
were we going to guess that
not only does immunity to the disease
come from the vaccine
but that uh immunity to transmitting it
also comes from the vaccine and
therefore
we will do more good if we deploy it in
a neighborhood that has less control
over the spread of this thing because
people are packed densely together or
something like that you can make a
perfectly valid
uh bioethical argument for it but even
though there are a couple of logical
leaps there that aren't founded
yet just because no one has bothered to
figure out but they're not you know you
could imagine
that the look i i think chances are
that if we understand the vaccines
correctly in terms of what they do
that they are also highly likely to
reduce transmission right
it's not certain i hope yeah well it's
not certain but the point is
you know there are reasons that you
could imagine that that would likely
fall
we just don't know yet so you could
build a policy that would protect those
who are most likely you know protect
communities that are most likely to have
this thing spreading in an uncontrolled
fashion
and that would be racially biased but to
put race first in their analysis
you know this is this is the road to
hell yeah i agree
[Music]
you